mayor of liverpool joe anderson
announced he's going to step aside from
his position
following his arrest last week a miracle
that he was arrested on friday
on suspicion of conspiracy to commit
bribery
and witness intimidation as well the
labour party
suspended him it was all about the
awarding of building contracts in the
city
a year-long investigation by the police
he said he was interviewed for six hours
last week he was elected mayor liverpool
back in
2012 having been on the council since
1998.
a bit more information about the mayor
of liverpool joe anderson who
said he's going to step aside uh from
his position uh he's released a
statement saying i've always done what i
believe is best for the city uh and i'm
taking the following action
with those best intentions uh in mind
uh he says he's stepping away from
decision-making within the council
through a period of unpaid leave until
the police make
clear their intentions was the
investigation on the 31st
of december they are investigating a
number of allegations against him and a
number of men
and they have said that they should be
able to make a statement by that date
joe anderson says i will make a further
statement at that point wendy simon will
be acting as mayor and i have all faith
she'll provide the leadership our city
requires at this
time